bonjour alexis trop de merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre
aujourd'hui de ce sommet entre
aleksandar vucic abdullah outils et
recettes bourrel on se souvient on vient
de le voir avec le sujet de grégoire
douce et à début juillet les tentatives
d' emmanuel macron et d'angela merkel
n'avait pas vraiment porté leurs fruits
qu'est ce qui va changer aujourd'hui
finalement pas grand chose vous l'avez
remarqué ou même l'ailé les deux
dirigeants l'un serbe et l'autre
albanais du kosovo qui était pieds
poings liés finalement deux d'entre eux
ont signé un accord purement technique
un accord sur les infrastructures les
routes même la 5g
mais rien sur la question fondamentale
qui est celle de est-ce qu'il faut
reconnaître l'indépendance du kosovo est
donc on voit bien de l'être mais très
pragmatique il a fait un tout petit pas
c'est à dire il a amené ses deux
dirigeants balkanique a signé un accord
en technique et commercial mais
maintenant le plus dur reste à faire
c'est l'union européenne qui doit
absolument trouver une solution sur
cette question de ce qui est et reste
toujours la province méridionale de la
serbie c'est à dire le kosovo métochie
et est ce que justement il va y avoir
une avancée tout à l'heure alors ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que la dette
la semaine dernière et cesser ces
derniers mois autant la partie albanaise
du kosovo s'est affaibli au même moment
où la partie serbe s'est renforcée alors
je vous expliquais les les albanais du
kosovo ont une élection il ya un peu
plus de deux mois
suite à laquelle un gouvernement n'a pas
pu se former et donc c'est un dirigeant
très affaibli à belley beauty qui s'est
présenté devant toi mais qui aujourd'hui
à bruxelles
pourquoi mais parce que ni le président
du kosovo qui est poursuivi pour quand
même des affaires très grave à la
justice internationale
ni les principaux ministres n'ont vu
n'ont voulu participer à cette opération
contre côté serbe avec son harrouch itx
fort d'une élection remportée haut la
main au moins de juin est beaucoup plus
stable si vous voulez dans ces
négociations et donc la partie serbe
peut quand même avancé plus
favorablement et donc bruxelles va
essayer dans cette configuration là de
demander à la serbie de ferments
d'honorables et de d'aller vers une
reconnaissance ce que aucun gouvernement
serbe n'accepte rai pourquoi parce que
le kosovo métochie
c'est le coeur de la serbie c'est au
coeur de l'identité serbe et ça reste
encore en droit international
une province méridionale de la serbie
selon la résolution 12 144 alexis trout
vous avez parlé d' aleksandar vucic qui
sera renforcée mais pourtant on a vu une
image sujette à interprétation depuis
vendredi elle est même devenue virale
sur les réseaux sociaux
celle donc d'aleksandar which le
président serbe interloqué à l'annoncé
de l'accord de déménagement de
l'ambassade serbe en israël de tel aviv
à jérusalem lorsque donald trump en
parle quel est votre interprétation vous
de de cette vidéo
beaucoup de bruit pour rien ou réelle
interrogation moi je pense que quand
même beaucoup de bruit pour rien bon en
certes il été décontenancé pourquoi
parce que sur le moment il ne s'y
attendait pas on se souvient à la
méthode de trucks et celle qu'avait eue
clinton dans les années 90 lorsqu'elle
est réuni les dirigeants serbes
bosniaques et croates l'époque il
il est décontenancé à ce moment là
puisque reconnaître israël ça veut dire
peut-être peut-être en droit
international
revenir sur la résolution tout 54 qui
dit que le kosovo métochie fait partie a
servi
mais c'est un peu un coup d'épée dans
l'eau da par le train parce que la
question principale qu'est ce qu'on
appelle le point 10 qui est celle de la
les bras du kosovo n'a pas été mis sur
la table et cette indépendance
on va commencer à en parler uniquement
aujourd'hui à bruxelles et je pense
qu'il faudra des mois entiers pour
arriver à un accord entre la serbie et
la partie avant du kosovo mais je le
répète aucun grand serbe même ouchichi
ne pourra imposer à sa population de se
couper d'une partie historique de son
territoire
mais vous vous dites il a été
décontenancé mais cette cette volonté là
de faire déplacer là l'ambassade de tel
aviv à jérusalem ce n'a pas été négocié
par aleksandar vucic éparses à cette
éducation quand il l'apprend à ce moment
là il n'est surpris je ne suis pas dans
les petits souliers de du grand serre
mais non il n'a pas été ça n'a pas été
négocié je ne crois pas pourquoi le
grand cerf depuis deux ans réussit à une
opération magistral qui est de faire
revenir un certain nombre de pays sur
leur décision de reconnaître
l'indépendance du kosovo
vous avez pas moins de vingt pays ces
dernières années grâce à une diplomatie
assez habile de la part du grand serre
qui sont revenus sur la décision de
reconnaître le kosovo est donc
aujourd'hui vous avez à peu près d'une
centaine de pays sur 193 à l'oeil nu qui
n'ont pas obtenu peu souvent et donc je
ne vois pas en quoi cette cet acte
concernant israël en rirait ce processus
qui voit un certain nombre de pays se
rendre compte que donnait le droit à un
groupe politique de se séparer d'un pays
en temps de paix sera un précédent
historique est très dangereux pour
n'importe quel pays dans le monde et
donc je pense si vous voulez que c'est
un processus historique qui fait que le
kosovo ne sera en tout cas pas dans les
prochaines
déchéance une par une une nation
indépendante
merci alex litres ou d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur en géographie en géopolitique
spécialiste des balkans auteur notamment
du livre balkans la fracture aux
éditions xenia